[Música]
buenas noches para todos primero que
nada gracias por estar acá acompañando
antes que nada me gustaría presentarme
mucho sierra fire frame tengo 33 años
nací acá como bien decían ahí atrás
estaba mi familia mis hermanos mis
padres
si acaba de la escuela fariseo y se
exporta en diferentes clubes y además
cuando terminó liceo tuve la suerte de
poder irme un año a israel a compartir
una experiencia con otros jóvenes judíos
sobre todo de latinoamérica pero otras
partes del mundo también en otros mí no
este año me volví a montevideo
empezó estudiar ciencias de comunicación
especialmente publicidad hice un montón
de cosas algunas de ellas como esas las
habrán visto que les suene el comercial
de suárez y ha habitado y la campaña y
short niño para paysandú me acuerdo que
cuando salió el aire mi abuela me llamó
emocionada a contarme que una hierba
de hecho una canción a paysandú y que
estaba lindísima la emoción que tuvo
cuando él dije le he hecho yo fue
impresionante
entonces me imagino que ustedes se
estarán preguntando y que tiene rafa
para compartir yo crecí acá como tantos
de ustedes como sus hijos o como sus
sobrinos o muchos hermanos que tiene
diferente para compartir y la verdad es
que cuando me llamaron yo mixta la misma
pregunta yo también me pregunto que
tengo acá para compartir bonita
instancia me seguido para hacer un
ejercicio o hacer un ejercicio interno y
pensar y aprovechar la oportunidad para
compartir con ustedes algunas cosas que
me parecen relevantes sobre la
reinvención
la primera historia tiene que suceden
chile en el 2015 me mudé a chile hacer
un máster en innovación y me acuerdo que
estaba recién llegado empezando a
entender cómo funcionaba la ciudad cómo
funcionaban los medio de transporte y
hago un paréntesis hay que reconocer que
pasando las calles están súper
ordenaditas se está el plano de paysandú
ya que es el de santiago de chile-
imaginarse una ciudad de 7 millones de
personas
la cosa que estaba apurado de nuestra si
estaba haciendo un entrevista trabajo
estaba haciendo una clase no recuerdo
bien pero recuerdo que iba caminando ya
unos 30 o 40 metros vi a un viejo que
tocaba una flauta entonces no sé por qué
por alguna razón me llamó la atención en
el que mirándolo pero no me quedé
mirándolo a él me quedé mirando a la
gente que estaba alrededor que pasaba y
caminaba que se acercaba
luego lo interesante de esto es que la
gente que estaba pasando por ahí no le
estaba dando nada no está dando monedas
no está dando miradas nos está dando la
sonrisa en nada no interactuaba con esta
persona y me quedé mirando pensando
porque podía pasar esto de verdad que no
encontré este mucha respuesta
pero cuando me acerqué cuando tuve que
pasar por ahí obligado para ir a la
parada del metro quizá por sentirme algo
de vergüenza o sentir que lo había
estado usando de una manera por mirarlo
de lejos está aquí en mi bolsillo alguna
moneda que tenía y se las tiré en la
latita que tenía pidiendo por supuesto
monedas
y a partir de ahí de esa instancia de
ese ruidito que cayeron las monedas
pasaron increíble nos anima a decir que
puede haber pasado en ese momento cuando
se dice las monedas acá para que uno
puede pensar bueno él se detuvo y le
agradeció él no pasa nada eso le sigue
tocando la flauta como si nada lo que
pasó fue que en el instante en el cual
yo le dejé las monedas otras personas
que estaban pasando por ahí de no sé qué
reacción hubo pero también le dieron
esas monedas también hicieron el gesto
de sacar moneda del bolsillo y darle y
con esas dos o tres personas hicieron lo
mismo dos o tres vinieron atrás
y entonces de que me di cuenta en estos
pocos minutos que pasaron no sé si fue
después la reflexión de que me di cuenta
de que estamos todos nosotros
constantemente que está construyendo
micro tendencias cuando una persona es
una acción en el trabajo en la escuela
en la familia en la casa donde decía
estamos de alguna manera impulsando esa
realidad para un lugar o para el otro
estas tendencias pueden ser buenas o
pueden ser malas nunca de paso que están
en una situación y dicen algo de más o
de menos y de repente empieza a escalar
o nunca les pasó que dijeron algo lindo
y de repente estuvieron algo lindo de
vuelta y de repente la situación cambió
hay una frase que me gusta mucho que es
de rambo maimónides que es un pensador
muy antiguo que dice que cada hombre
debe verse a sí mismo todo el año como
si estuviera equilibrado mitad o bien y
mitad o mal también debe ver al mundo
como si tuviera equilibrado entre el
bien y el mal
esta frase repite algunas algunas cosas
pero la invitación que nos está haciendo
está la reflexión que tuve después de
esa pequeña experiencia es que ojalá
nosotros todos pudiéramos pensar nos
como estamos constantemente en
equilibrio y pasar la realidad de un
lugar a otro solamente depende de
nosotros depende de mí y ustedes que
están sentados ahí
entonces claro un viejo que toca la
flauta le hablo de rambam grito que
tiene que ver con la reinvención y la
verdad que nada no tiene sacar unas
dimensiones a situación de la misma
persona no cambien mucho mis actitudes
más o menos soy el mismo de siempre
solamente que incorpore algunas
experiencias
la hace una historia tiene que ver con
la perspectiva hace algunos meses del
mayo específicamente tuve la suerte de
ir a canadá trabajo una empresa
tecnología llama móvil y tuve suerte de
ir a canadá una conferencia a toronto si
vas el trabajo que hicimos en uno de los
momentos libres subimos esta torre esta
torre se llama la cinta walk que
básicamente es una torre muy alta como
pueden ver tiene 153 metros de altura y
lo que pueden ver ahí
y esto qué tal es un restaurant que gira
el piso está girando entonces eso te
permite ver toda la ciudad mientras
estás comiendo mientras estabas esté
esperando tiene más o menos 450 metros
de altura
cuando me senté ahí mirar para afuera lo
que me pareció a tan sólo 450 metros y
que parecía todo de juguete los
edificios eran parecen cajitas de
zapatos los autos parecen autos de
colección y las personas eran
literalmente irreconocibles no sabía si
eran personas muñecos animales eran
irreconocibles no puedes distinguir
entre una persona u otra entonces
está ahí mirando para abajo y qué fue lo
que pensé desde desde arriba no más
entré muy orgulloso pero esto fue lo que
esto fue lo que pensé
mirando las personas chiquitas se lo
dije seguro que algunos están de mal
humor porque está con el teléfono sin
batería o le duele una muela a 400
metros un dolor de muela y si es
imperceptible o sea un un dolor de muela
una batería descargada una remera que no
encontré el taller pierdes completamente
el sentido o sea 400 metros no tiene
sentido estar preocupándose por esas
perdón estupideces
el siguiente estoy yo el siguiente
pensamiento fue si yo me viera a mí
mismo a 450 metros enojado porque no se
le rompen al me daría vergüenza y ahí
puede haber cualquier otra cosa está el
ejemplo dirección al próximo ejemplo en
parece que por todos vamos entrar pero
nadie puede hacer cualquier cosa
superficial ponerse no tienen una tipo
de profundidad
y lo decía antes a 450 metros de altura
somos irreconocibles
la conclusión de esta parte es que tan
solo unos pocos metros si pensamos en
400 metros son cuatro cuadras que lo
caminamos en tres minutos cuatro minutos
cinco minutos son suficientes a veces
para ver la vida ahora el mundo ver el
universo con una perspectiva diferente y
nuestra forma de entenderlo y creo de
verdad que si de vez en cuando
pudiéramos tomar un poquito de
perspectiva todos seríamos mejores y la
sociedad mejoraría proporcionalmente
en ese momento mi promesa fue no
calentarme más por boludeces no
presentar más nacionales romper al no
reventar además si esas cosas que en
realidad no estaban la esencia de la
vida este me afectará si la verdad que a
veces el respeto de mi promesa y a veces
no
a veces me siguió calentando por tú
pienses pero intento tener eso calmado y
de nuevo qué tiene que ver esto con la
dimensión
y algunos puede empezar a ser una
conexión para inicialmente también tuvo
una experiencia tuve un pensamiento de
una reflexión y ahora que de
reinventarme tiene un poco
la tercera historia
tiene que ver con mi padre y hoy no les
voy a contar nada con respecto a su
asesinato por el hecho de ser judíos no
le voy a contar lo maravilloso que era
no le voy a contar esas cosas que habrán
escuchado o leído pero bueno que me
hacen caras lo que le voy a contar es
algo que pasó la última vez que lo vi
mi hermano vive en londres hermano
gabriel en este momento de ver a
montevideo yo vivía en chile y por
alguna razón mi hermano guillermo había
sacado un pasaje desde londres a buenos
aires supongo que encontrar mejor precio
la verdad que no recuerdo la cosa que
hice sigo un sábado nosotros los que
vamos paseando hasta el día siguiente el
día siguiente me acompaña en el
aeropuerto
recuerdo estaba mi hermana estaba mi
madre y me acuerdo que en el momento de
irme de desembarcar me acuerdo que yo
por alguna razón no le pude decir te
quiero le dije te voy a extrañar
y quizás por eso es que hoy cada vez que
hablo con mi madre con mi abuela que
están por ahí se lo diré todo mías todos
los días a mi novia pero no puedo parar
de decir esas cosas no puedo parar de
decir te quiero te extraño extraño es
una cosa que no puedo controlar no lo es
más mi madre de 6 para rafa mira está
diciendo mucho pierde un poco valor y
capa que tiene un poco de razón si uno
dice todos los días lo mismo se
transforma rutina nunca vieron que las
salidas de emergencia no sabemos dónde
están porque está ahí pasamos en cuanto
a veces nos vemos y capo aquí tienes
efectos de estar constantemente
repitiendo estas cosas pero la verdad
que personalmente prefiero decir esta
cosa de más que decir lo de menos
es cierto que en esta historia hay un
comportamiento que se modifica su
incorpora un hábito que yo quiero algo
propósito pero es simplemente me surge
pero de nuevo no hay reinvención acá
la última historia corta que les quiero
compartir es pasó en chile también en el
2015 estaba recién llegado estamos en
arriba de la montaña
en la universidad que es la universidad
increíble y el ejercicio constaba de
separarse en pequeños grupos y en estos
pequeños grupos de cinco o seis personas
saben que compartir cada uno que sueños
teníamos y digamos que decir porque
todavía no lo habíamos cumplido yo no sé
si tenía el objetivo de integrarnos con
el resto quizá en el grupo podía haber
alguien que nos ayuda a facilitar ese
sueño
no sé cuál tenía pero
es el objetivo
y ya tenemos que contar porque no
estábamos haciendo realidad
yo conté en ese momento que el mío era
conocer el mundo yo estaba pensando en
conocer diferentes países con esas
diferentes personas pero en diferentes
comidas diferentes culturas estaba no sé
por qué en ese momento es eso fue lo que
yo compartí
y le dije esta fiesta ese momento y le
dije a él carlos como yo quiero conocer
a el mundo como buscarlos es el
vicerrector de la universidad el
vicerrector de internacionalización
dos tres veces por mes es sobre un avión
en el aeropuerto aterriza en el destino
del hotel como si conoce 12 50 60 70
países
entonces cuando yo conté que yo quería
conocer el mundo
esa misma esta expresión es que como
buscarlos cada uno después sigue la
vuelta y cada una es cuestiã que
reflexionar con respecto al sueño del
otro entonces carlos en ese momento me
dijo algo que me hizo un clic y me dijo
rafa hay dos maneras de conocer el mundo
una es como estoy conociendo yo voy al
aeropuerto hago me felicita señor
aeropuerto destino me pasan a buscar voy
a un restaurant voy al hotel
duermo voy a trabajar doy una vueltita
como de vuelo
y otra manera de conocer el mundo como
estás haciendo voz joven hitachi le
incorpora la cultura debemos incorporar
hemos trabajado no a la fuerza laboral
vamos a conocer las costumbres más ricas
de chile y realmente vas a estar
conociendo el mundo que no lo está
conociendo todo pero está conociendo uno
en profundidad
y yo en ese momento dije a la pucha
estoy cumpliendo mi sueño y no me había
dado cuenta yo lo estaba cumpliendo el
sueño estaba expresando que yo lo estaba
cumpliendo
y lo que parece que muchas veces por
estar pendiente de lo que podría pasar
nos estamos volviendo de lo que está
pasando estamos constantemente un poco
relacionado con lo que se llaman horas
un rato constantemente que lo que pasa
afuera con lo que podría pasar lo que lo
que podríamos estar haciendo y nos
olvidamos del aquí y ahora lo estamos
olvidando de lo que está pasando en este
momento en mi vida o la vida que tengo
alrededor
entonces pregunto esta experiencia hizo
como reinventará y la respuesta de nuevo
en no yo no me realmente no soy una
persona nueva
por ahora derecho de esto el emperador
vivió esta experiencia por haber pensado
esto se me ocurrieron pero entonces rafa
a dónde quieres llegar con esto es una
charla de reinvención de historias de
gente que cuenta pequeñas pequeñas
instantes de su vida de reinvención y lo
que me di cuenta pensaba esta charla y
yo por eso hablé con la oportunidad
ahora detenido y cuando me invitaron
pensaba que nunca me había reinventado
pero por qué porque estaba pensando la
reinvención a mí esa palabra la que la
conectaba con la reinvención como las
películas ámbitos las películas las
cuales el deportista se pone los zapatos
se pone la vincha vale va al gimnasio y
es un fenómeno o es emprendedor que he
comprado computadora se encuentra cuenta
con dos amigos y de repente es un
emprendedor impresionante
yo estaba asociando la reinvención a la
cosa que pasa inmediatamente que pasa de
vestir rápido sense y la rojita
equivocado
bueno lo que dice porque está pensando
mal
la reinvención no tiene que ser absoluta
no tiene que ser inmediata y no tiene
que ser para siempre que estaba pensando
antes no tiene que ser así
es un error
para reinventarse quizás entiendo me
mates pero quizás no hace faltan
procesos o protocolos o grandes cosas
hace falta solamente estar atento estar
despierto ser prestado atención
yo soy el mismo
de antes de haber pasado todo esto y soy
el mismo después de haber pasado esto
soy el mismo de siempre espera mismo
tiempo para reinventarme entonces los
invito de alguna manera a pensar que la
reinvención no tiene por qué estar como
mencionaba antes
entre terminar les quiero dejar una
última cosa y es que cuando cuando vayan
a sus casas hoy cuando vayan a sus
trabajos cuando hablen con sus parejas o
con un amigo lo que sea díganle que los
quieren porque quizás no les ayudan a
reinventarse no les cambió la vida pero
quizá les puedan ganar la vida después
pueden cambiar el día a ellos o ustedes
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
a
hola
[Música]